- I was to have revenge for
every woman that ever had her
hands
laid on by a man, for my mother,
my sister, Tina Turner...
[laughter]
Rihanna.
[engine revs]
[dark electronic music]
♪
[mouthing words]
[gunshot]
[heart beating]
[roars]
[gunshots]
[growls]
[roars]
[cheers and applause]
- I'm really excited to bring
this guy up.
I've been watching him seven,
eight, ten years, every night--
every Tuesday at The Comedy
Store.
And you guys are gonna love him.
Please give it up for my friend
and yours, Scruncho, everybody.
Let him hear it.
Scruncho.
[cheers and applause]
- My beautiful sister was in a
domestic violence relationship.
As I got older, I realized by
brother-in-law was beating
the fuck out of my beautiful
sister.
So like a man, I pulled him
aside,
I look him in the eye, and I
tell him, you know, I say,
"Dre," I say, "Now, you know,
you puttin' your hands on my
sister, and she continue to go
back to you," right?
Now, ain't nothin' more
disrespectful than when you're
telling a grown man what you
feeling in your heart and soul,
and in the middle of your
heartfelt conversation,
that other grown man gonna look
at you and "pssh" you.
That's what I said.
I said did this bitch nigga
just "pssh" me?
Now, sometimes, ladies, you've
got to give a man exactly
what he been dishing out in
order for him to have
understanding of the fuck what
he been doing to you.
But here's the thing.
Whenever a man
go to discipline another grown
man,
the fight is no longer physical.
The fight is spiritual.
And my mother taught me when I
was 12, she was like,
"If you defended the honor of
your sisters,
"God would put a covenant over
you.
"The angels would covenant you.
"Angels will protect you.
"The heavens will protect you.
"And God will not allow you to
lose that battle, because it's
a spiritual, biblical battle, so
you cannot and will not lose."
So at that point, ladies and
gentlemen, I hung on my spirit,
'cause I knew there was gonna be
a day in time when I must give
Dre this biblical, spiritual
ass-whuppin' his body
so desperately desired.
Two weeks later, the shit hit
the fan.
That same sister was having a
taco party.
And just for the record,
real niggas eat more tacos than
Mexicans.
And if y'all don't remember
nothing about my whole show,
remember this: don't y'all trust
no man
that eat less than three tacos.
[laughter]
The fuck you nibblin' for?
Now, I'm sitting in the middle
of the living room
eating my six tacos, and I swear
to God,
what I seen in the kitchen, it
breaks my heart to this day.
I see my beautiful sister that
raised me, walked me to school,
taught me my ABCs, my beautiful
sister.
My brother-in-law got my
beautiful sister in the corner
like she's some type of fuckin'
roach
stompin' my sister in the chest
as if she didn't come from the
womb of my beautiful mother,
socking my beautiful sister in
the eye as if she
didn't have brothers to defend
her honor.
Immediately, ladies and
gentlemen,
I disconnected from my physical
world.
I went into a spiritual world.
And it was just like my mother
said.
The heavens opened up.
I seen my mother's face appear
with a halo over her head.
And I heard that biblical music
go...
♪ Ahh-ahh-ahh-ahh
And then the angels came around.
And at that point, ladies and
gentlemen,
I feel the spirit of God come
through me,
and I did not run over there to
protect my beautiful sister.
I did not walk aggressively over
there to protect
my beautiful sister.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I floated over there.
I floated, and I rosed up on
that motherfuckin' Dre,
and guess what, ladies and
gentlemen.
I was the big man.
He was the little man.
And let me tell every woman in
here something.
I was to have revenge for every
woman that ever had her
hands
laid on by a man, for my mother,
my sister, Tina Turner...
[laughter]
Rihanna.
And as I rose up over him, the
spirit of Floyd Mayweather
shot through my body.
My hands swoll up as if I was 50
and 0.
It was the size of a Floyd
Mayweather boxing glove.
With all the strength God gave
me,
right before I went to hit him
with these undefeated hands,
Dre hit me so many times,
I thought I was getting jumped.
At this point, I realized
something.
This motherfucker Dre was gifted
from the shoulders.
Ladies and gentlemen, his hand
speed was incredible.
At that point, I realized
something.
I've got to go get my best
friend.
And I don't know--let me tell
you, there's some rules
when you go get your best friend
in the hood.
Number one rule: ain't no rules.
I go get my best friend.
We get to the point of location,
and I tell my best friend,
I say--I look him in the eye,
and he a gangster motherfucker.
I said, "Dulo--I said, "Nigga,
you ready to die?"
He had me fooled like a
motherfucker.
He started Crip walking.
He said, "I don't give a fuck."
[laughter]
So we get to my sister's house.
He got the 9-millimeter.
I got the motherfucking handgun.
And right before we knocked at
the door,
I looked him in my one good eye,
and I no longer was on that
spiritual shit.
Me and the devil was in cahoots.
I looked at him with a wicked--I
said, "Motherfucker,
is you ready to die?"
He said, "I don't give a fuck."
So we knock at the door.
Now my sister come to the door.
She come to me and said, "What's
happening?"
I said, "Whoopty-whoopty-whoo."
She said,
"Whoopty-whoopty-whoo."
I said, "Whoopty-whoopty-whoo."
"Whoopty-whoopty-whoo" means "et
cetera, et cetera, et cetera."
[laughter]
Now, at that point, she come and
open the door.
Now, the person y'all see now
did not exist.
I'm telling y'all, I had a
spirit on me that was so
motherfucking wicked, when I
walked in there, I swear to God,
let me tell you how sick I was.
I was gonna shoot pictures,
wedding pictures, images,
ideals,
I didn't give a fuck.
Look, I got a little nephew
named little Dre
who looked just like big Dre.
Little Dre is bad a
motherfucker.
I would have shot him twice.
I take four, five steps in the
house,
my sister jump her fat ass on my
back,
wrap her thigh around my waist,
and tried to weigh a real nigga
down.
Now, due to the obesity of her
weight,
a real nigga was going down.
But my trigger hand was free.
Who do I see?
I see motherfucking Dre, Dre see
me, and he grabbed my arm.
Now, my sister, we begin to
struggle for the gun.
Now, this bitch nigga Dre do
something
I think was kind of clever.
He come from the blind side of
my bad eye.
I thought he had some type of
magical skills.
He jumped on me like, "Ya!"
Trying to scared me,
and he did.
I was like, "Oh, shit."
Now, at that point, the gun
dislodges from my hand.
Dre picks up the handle of the
gun,
begins to whup my ass for the
second time.
Now, as Dre is whipping my ass
at a a rhythm pace,
I couldn't help but to think,
"Where is my best friend?"
[laughter]
Now, as I looked in the position
that I was in in my
fetal position, I looked toward
the window that I entered.
To the left of the door was a
window.
On the outside of the window,
there was my best friend
looking in at me
as I'm get my ass really
whupped.
And I said, "I thought you said
you was ready to die."
He looked at me, he said,
"Not like that."
[laughter]
And at this point, Dre's punches
was phenomenal.
I was two punches from death.
I had no choice.
I had to give my best friend
encouragement.
So I yelled back.
I said, "But, Dulo,
you got a gun, best friend."
And he yelled back,
"But you had one too."
And at this point, blood is
coming out my pores.
He had a wicked left hook.
He hit me in this ear and
knocked my hearing
completely out.
I seen Dulo running, and to make
a long story short,
the police came, and guess who
went to jail.
Me.
But I got good news, and I got
bad news.
The good news is, my sister was
fuckin' in court
to fuckin' bail me out of jail.
How about that?
The bad news is, she brought Dre
with her.
[laughter]
And to make bad news worse,
the judge put a restraining
order on me to stay away from
Dre and Dre to stay away from
me,
which was a blessing to me.
And my sister hit me with the
information
that I would never, ever forget.
And these words make me--I would
never, ever
defend my sister again.
I looked at her with all the
compassion in my eyes,
and I said, "What the fuck is
wrong with you?
Don't you know blood is thicker
than water?"
And what she replied fucked me
up.
And she said, "Don't you know
come is thicker than blood?"
[laughter]
[dark electronic music]
♪